I won't give you feedback that I got
from from listeners Sean you ready am I
prepared for this is this harsh critical
whew that's good - okay great no okay so
what I'm noticing with this podcast is
we have a similar amount of views each
week and I think it's the same people
over and over I think we're like part of
people's routine which is cool and the I
think that one of the secrets to growing
a podcast is do you have to have guests
so when we had Andrew he shared it I saw
people who like him came and listened
and I hope we've got him hooked and
they're gonna listen from now on and so
the way that we're gonna do this is
we're just gonna get more guests but
here's what people keep telling me and
this they weren't saying this about
Andrew but they like it when it's just
you and I rip in it and just making
up on the fly yeah yeah I felt that and
I think it's even more on these zoom
calls because the zoom called pace a
little slower when we're in person it's
a little bit better I think to have that
third guest on the seat and it
definitely depends their guests got to
bring the bring to energy you can't just
be successful in smart that is not
enough you have to bring energy you got
to know what people want to hear about
and get to the point and so you know
that's the the rubric for guest which is
hard when you're also trying to find
famous guests because they help to show
grow and just for the record Sean and I
have recorded with I think we've done a
bunch of times I personally have done it
a bunch of times and it was wonderful
people who I like and it just turned out
to be bad and we just don't publish yeah
we throw it away and we don't even talk
we just throw it away yeah and I've done
it like four throughout the years for
whatever I don't even remember what I
was recording stuff for I've interviewed
someone who was like an amazing operator
and the content was wack and I'm like
well trash it so anyway the feedback
that we're getting so is that people
like us because they say that I'm more
optimist and you're more like
down-to-earth and that we're if and they
love that and that they can't get that
anywhere but you and I are like let's go
get more guests and people don't like to
guess unfortunately that helps us grow
yeah well we'll keep mixing it in dude I
had a call yesterday that I was like if
I had just recorded this this would have
been like one of the dopest podcasts
ever it was just me and for a con we
have a call every once a week now that's
just called cool and he lives in
like the edge of like technology he's
like in the dark web basically that not
in a legal way but sort of like he's on
the forefront of what's interest like an
he's just a nerd he's just like a very
typical Silicon Valley engineer just
yeah he knows reality a good way he
knows me well enough and also he loves
money enough where he knows how to take
that stuff and bubble up the bits that
are interesting the bits that are
relevant and not just get lost in the
weeds of technology so that cover was
amazing but unfortunately didn't record
the other thing was gonna say about the
guest is being guest on other people's
podcast is the other way to grow so I
had a Shawn let yesterday reach out to
like 50 podcasts and just be like hey
I'll go on and talk about it right like
I'll go on I just sold my company I can
go on and talk about that hey we built a
podcast that did a million downloads in
the first six months we could talk about
how we did that and so I think guesting
on other people's podcast might be a
good way you did this with Gary Vee with
pomp so yeah I probably so there's a
caveat there I've I've probably been a
guest a hundred times and there was a
period like over the trailing six months
I have it set on my calendar from three
o'clock to five o'clock that's only
guessing on podcast and I would do it
and some of the small ones just drove
nothing right like it was total hit or
miss and so I would spend like three
weeks doing it and it's almost like and
you probably like this it's like being
the comedian you just say this same
over and over and you kind of figure out
what hits and it's fun it's almost like
therapy you just talk about yourself
it's cool but it definitely gets a
little repetitive and it the results are
not always there but they are sometimes
yeah and you know the thing you said at
the beginning which is for podcasting
you get this base and it's the sticky
sticky base of people who want to listen
to it all the time it becomes a part of
the routine they start to really love
you that sort of thing it's very
different than other products I built
where I'm like alright I want to get
millions of users to just visit this
page or like just use this once a week
or subscribe to this and kind of
like that's been a lot of the products I
built this is the opposite it's like an
army of a hundred thousand people who
will like go to war for you I think
there's people in this group that would
if I said hey I need you to beat this
person up they would go beat that person
up like there's people who really have
your back and when I started this I
remember I was talking to su Lee who's
the very first guest on the pod and he
was like you know what do you think it
makes you just sold the company and I
was like you know I really like this
podcast thing it was okay like is that a
business like in some ways it's a step
down right it's like I'm gonna wait way
less doing this than I did my last
business or any other business I want to
do and I was like look I want to just be
in like a million people's ear balls
every morning if I did that I just know
that that's a good thing and I don't
know how to get there but I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna get into a million
people's ear balls every morning on
their way to work and the way to work I
think that's powerful
yeah I mean it may or may not be a
business but it definitely will lead to
way more opportunity yeah I've had a lot
of I mean I've been doing the content
thing a little bit like before the
podcast so I kind of understand it but
the podcast definitely is different I
remember I went to New York salon and I
just tweeted I was like I'm we're gonna
be over I'm gonna be over here because I
was there for a hustle advertising crap
and I just tweeted as like yeah I want
to be here I had 200 people want to come
and so we only let maybe 20 come and
because we're in people's ears dude like
these people this kid Ryan said
something to me and he's like yeah you
know cuz you said how much you liked
this thing and I was like I don't
remember what you're talking about
and like they think they know you and
you know the other thing I like is that
people or the people who is this are
actually pretty really really smart and
successful you know I think a lot of
podcasts that are about business they
cater to kind of lowest common
denominator so it's like oh the waltrip
renewer is their core market and you
know in our facebook group for this
podcast I posted something saying hey
I'm doing something cool for people who
have a business that does over a million
dollars a year and there's like a
hundred plus replies just in that
Facebook group of people who have
businesses doing over a million dollars
a year right so these are not like kind
of like the want reproduce you know
they're not
job or a college kid or something like
that like of course there are people
like that but the audience also is mixed
with a lot of interesting successful
people there's a bunch of VCS that
listen to this it's crazy
so anyways enough about the podcast
let's give people some some other topics
or ideas
[Music]